well february is a month of love it is
also american heart month
the goal is to motivate us to adopt
healthy lifestyles to prevent heart
disease
bianca holman live with more on that hi
bianca good morning
hey good morning alex morning everybody
at home so yeah february
is american heart month and now more
than ever it's so important to take
charge of your health
and to start moving whatever you have to
do if it's
taking a walk outside going to the gym
of course with your mask on
and getting active but hitting the
treadmill lifting some weights
is what you can do to combat heart
disease now we were able to talk with
the
southern nevada health district and they
tell us that heart disease is one of the
leading causes of death
for americans and especially for women
one in three women are diagnosed with
heart disease annually
people with poor cardiovascular health
are also at increased risk of severe
illness from coven 19.
that's according to the national heart
lung and blood institute
during the covet 19 pandemic many people
have delayed or avoided going to the
hospital for heart attacks and strokes
we spoke with the health district and
they tell us that high blood pressure
is the leading factor to heart disease
blood pressure is the amount of force it
takes to get blood throughout your body
the american heart association
recommends 2 300 milligrams of sodium
intake daily
that's about one teaspoon of salt the
average american actually gets more
salt intake in their daily diet about 3
400 milligrams
and if a person has high blood pressure
or they are at risk for high blood
pressure
the recommended amount is 1500
milligrams of sodium
so that's less than a half a teaspoon
yeah time to put down that salt shaker
and lay off the sodium
here are some heart attack symptoms
chest discomfort
the pressure on your chest the squeezing
feeling shortness of breath that might
be signs that you could be having a
heart attack
now when it comes to strokes uh there's
the acronym called fast
face the start they starting to droop
arm weakness speech difficulty if you
experience any of that
the key is to call 9-1-1 immediately
don't wait
and of course to combat all of this
we're told 80 percent
of heart disease is preventable so it's
about what you put in your mouth what
we're eating
time to lay off some of that super bowl
food don't go ahead and throw it away do
not eat it today
but instead maybe go for a walk grab an
apple and
again make some healthy life choices
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now